one thing's very clear that i mean the
the
the northern ireland action was
withdrawn very quickly by the european
commission and quite rightly
and it's very important for people in
europe to understand and for people here
to understand the reason why
britain is so far ahead on the vaccines
being rolled out here
is not just because astrazeneca
obviously is is a vaccine developed here
in the uk
but we concluded our contracts faster
than the european commission
and so britain too by the way had delays
in the supply of our vaccine we were
anticipating
more astrozenica vaccine faster but it's
just that since we concluded our
contracts quite rightly and
all kudos to those that did this we're
10 to 12 weeks ahead of europe
now these problems in the end will get
resolved by mid-march there should be a
large amounts of vaccine flowing into
europe
and in the second quarter of the year
there'll be even
larger volumes but this is all arisen
and it's important we realize this
because it's a lesson for the future
this is arisen because policymakers
the world over thought at the beginning
of this
crisis that they would have the
following type of rhythm
with three phases first phase you lock
down and you control
the spread of the the virus second phase
you contain and control it as you wait
for the vaccine
third phase you keep those containment
measures and then you vaccinate over the
course of 2021.
what's basically happened with the new
strains much more transmissible
is that second phase is collapsed and so
countries are now faced with a situation
of mass lockdown or mass vaccination
therefore
the urgency for vaccine has become all
the greater
you know you make the point that the uk
is ahead of the eu on the vaccine roll
out because we were quicker
in signing those contracts you of course
were a very vocal supporter of remaining
in the eu but for many this would
demonstrate exactly why they think
brexit
is a good thing because we can be more
nimble we can have
less bureaucracy outside of europe yeah
of course we
we could have done this inside europe as
well there was no obligation on us to
join the european purchasing
arrangements and and of course at the
time we made our arrangements we were
still
um the transition period for europe
hadn't come to an end
but you know i'm well aware people will
make that point
and in any event i can't believe there
will be a situation
in the future where any major developed
country
is going to subcontract its purchasing
for
vaccine and therefore i think what is
important now i mean obviously
as i say i think in the next few weeks
as astrazeneca ramps up its production
for europe and remember its production
for the uk is coming predominantly from
uk plants
specifically contracted for the the the
uk market
but that problem will resolve itself
over the next few weeks
the really critical thing we've got to
ask now is how we make preparations
for the future because here is the
lesson that we have now learned
this mutation of the virus can happen at
any point in time
these mutations may require possibly
this strain we have here in the uk it's
almost certainly covered by existing
vaccine
the south africa strain we're not so
sure of but in the future
you may get a strain of the virus that's
not covered by existing vaccines
and therefore you're going to have to
make new ones and the question we've got
to ask ourselves
now is what are the preparations we need
to put in place
so that the time between finding out
you've got a new strain
developing a vaccine to deal with it
producing it and distributing
distributing it is vastly shortened so
that within a period literally of weeks
maybe maximum three months
you're you've got the surveillance in
place to spot the new strain
you've got the research and development
in place to be able to
to adjust your vaccine you've then got
the vaccines able to be produced
at mass at scale hundreds and hundreds
of millions or billions of doses
and then distributed what we should
learn from the
last few few months is that this
virus will mutate and we've therefore
got to be
much much faster in how we deal with it
some really big questions
of course that you raised there about
how we keep up to speed with the virus
that has
proven to be several steps ahead of us
so far this year
just very quickly finally on the eu
and before we move on to other things
because i do think you know you were
saying that they obviously
withdrew the triggering of article 16
very quickly which would have stopped
exports to northern ireland but at the
same time
you were of course you were somebody who
made ireland central to your arguments
for
why we should stay in the eu um
the european union throughout have said
how important it is to
avoid the hard border on the island of
ireland
and yet just a couple of weeks after
they signed the deal they end up
unilaterally creating one
without even telling anybody i
appreciate they withdrew it but it's
pretty
irresponsible isn't it that was this
very foolish thing to do
unfortunately they withdrew it very
quickly um but no
look it remains you know i was someone
who negotiated the good friday agreement
it spoke brought peace to the island of
ireland and
it's absolutely vital we protect it and
that's why what the european
um commission did was was unacceptable
but as you say fortunately they withdrew
it very quickly
but you know we're going to have to i
mean
this this is going to be a very
difficult few weeks
because for countries in europe
and you know germany has made its own
arrangements to get vaccine
and countries are going to be scrambling
for vaccine
in the developed world and indeed in the
developing world because as i say
what's happened is the contain and
control part of
of of the crisis has really evaporated
but this will i mean it will eventually
resolve itself because astrazeneca is
ramping up production all the time
but all of these issues you know in time
they sophie they
that they will resolve themselves for
this
phase of the crisis that's why i think
you've got to be even now looking at
what is necessary to do for the future
is there a point when we should think
about giving away
some of the vaccines that we have to
other countries
well that's only going to happen if
we've got a surplus a vaccine now
we like most developed countries have
um ordered more vaccine than we will
probably use
but but this is a decision that's got to
be taken once we see our own program
rolling out and and you know i'm sure
that would be by the way
for all of the developed world because
america for example has got massively
more vaccine order than it's ever going
to use there will come a point i'm sure
when
the developed world will want to make
sure if they have surplus to their own
requirements they'll want to share this
with
the developing world and indeed one of
the things i've been involved in with my
institute in the last couple of weeks is
making sure for example we can get
vaccines fast
to frontline health workers in africa
and africa itself
it has been ramping up its its um
uh forward purchasing of of vaccine
because
with this new strain that's developed in
africa
centered in south africa case levels are
going up in africa in a way they didn't
in the first
wave of this disease so you're gonna all
of these questions are going to get
um debated and and resolved
i come back to my point though right now
and britain's got the leadership of the
g7 so it's in a great
position uh to take leadership of this
issue but
right now we've got to be looking at how
we make sure we detect these new strains
far faster
how we're developing the right backbone
of the technology for new vaccines to
deal with any
other possible pathogens how we're going
to be able to shorten radically
any of the trials for these new vaccines
that we may need
and how we can then manufacture them at
scale it's never been
more important of course for people to
have confidence in
taking the vaccine um obviously we've
got quite high take-up rates in the uk
but not everybody
is prepared to do that this week we saw
emmanuel macron
saying everything points to thinking the
astrazeneca vaccine is
quasi ineffective on people older than
65
some say those 60 years or older the
early results we have
are not encouraging for 60 to 65 year
old people concerning astrazeneca
i mean scientists have lined up to say
this is untrue uh
the vaccine has been approved for use in
older people by both the european and
the uk regulators
how irresponsible do you think it is for
the french president to be
almost engaging in conspiracy theories
well
look i don't want to get into a big
round about it but it's obviously
incorrect let's say
um so um no there's no doubt the
astrozenica vaccine is
is a good vaccine and it's good vaccine
for
for people over the age of 60 over the
age of 65 and i've got a vested interest
in that nowadays so
um but by the way there are about eight
or nine vaccines
any of which personally i would be
perfectly happy to take
the problem that you've got is that
people want vaccination
now because of the severity of lockdown
but come the the middle of the year
frankly the developed world will be
pretty much a wash with wax
vaccine but the issue is going to be
how you you accelerate
the process of production and
distribution in the months up to them
because
with every month that passes and you're
not getting vaccine out to people
your risk is that you you get a mutation
of the disease
as i say for which your existing
vaccines aren't effective and you've
then got to be able
to switch to to adjust the vaccine and
switch course
very very fast how um
concerned are you talking about the new
variants do you think the government is
right to clamp down on travel
at a minute from different countries or
do you think they should go further than
the current um policy that they have
well you've obviously got to be making
sure if particularly if you've got facts
if you've got uh a variant that's going
to come in for example the south africa
ones
very very important to deal with um
and look you you're going to be in a
situation i think the reality is
where there is going to be severe
restrictions for some considerable
period of time
but i think you know one of the things
my institute's been working on is for
example
to to develop a common travel pass i
think this is going to be
inevitable in the end the only way
you're going to get people traveling
again is if they're able to prove either
vaccination
or testing status and do it by by means
that are verifiable
at the same time they saw it to jump in
um we don't have the evidence yet that
if you've had the vaccine whether or not
you can still transmit the virus so
would that really work
well i think that that evidence is is
building and growing by the way and one
of the
the reasons why i i'm so obsessive on
the issue of data
and i still don't think the world's
fully got its
the policy makers have got their mind
around the importance of being able to
assemble
the best possible data so that every
single vaccination you know what's
happened to
every individual and you're able to
follow up on what the consequences are
is that one of the things that that that
those parts of the data will show you
is whether um vaccination does reduce
transmission now the evidence out of
israel by the way is pretty
pretty good in that respect um but in
any event
you know whatever comes out of it and it
stands to reason that that if you are
vaccinated
you know you're and you you produce
those antibodies you're
less likely to be transmitting the
disease
countries are going to want to know what
your disease status is as they
let you into the country you um mention
restrictions there and how we may be
having to live with restrictions for
for quite a while at what point do you
think we can start easing
some of the restrictions and what
restrictions do you think we should
look at first it's it's
it's difficult because you just got to i
mean if we carry on ramping up the
the vaccination as we are at the moment
and
as the paper of my institute showed a
few weeks back
i think we will be able to accelerate
this through
february and march you know you would
hope
at some point in the next couple of
months you're starting to be able to
ease things
i i do think there's a very strong case
for
um for vaccinating teachers in order to
get the schools back
i mean i know there are arguments on
both sides of that but i'm
i'm i would be i would need a very
compelling argument
not to think it was a good idea to do
that um
and obviously as you start and i think
there's some evidence growing is it
of this even here as you as you start to
vaccinate
the the disease levels will come down
so do you think that teachers for
example should get a vaccine before the
over 60s over 50s if you decided you
wanted to vaccinate all the teachers
you could do it in a very short space of
time and yes i i know you you would
delay it
somewhat but you could you could
probably get that done in a couple of
days
and the point is that i mean i i know
there are arguments on the other side
and obviously
you know speaking of someone who's in
that age category um
you know of course i want the vaccine as
soon as possible but
i think on the other hand it's so
important to get the children back into
school so you'd give up your vaccine for
a teacher would you then
i i would well i'm suggesting i would i
would
push back it it's only a very you know
if it's 500 000 people it's two days of
vaccination
i i think i think it that is a
reasonable thing to do
in these circumstances if it helps allow
you to get
um the school's back sooner and
if you combine it with um testing which
we should do again
um obviously we've said that for a long
period of time we should be using many
more of these rapid antigen tests
if you combine it with that then you
could probably get the schools back
so you know when you're talking about
how you ease up restrictions
you'll be easing them up step by step i
think it's hard if you're in government
to give a very precise timetable on it
at the moment
but you would hope if you if as i say
the vaccination
program accelerates in the way that it
should that you should be
you know quite a strong position to do
it around about middle march at least
um is it true that you've been talking
to people in government
matt hancock for example and giving them
some advice on handling the pandemic
yeah first of all the stories that
appear about this there's nothing to do
with me and i don't put them there yes
of course i speak to people in
government
and um you know the work that my
institute does is
is trying you know not to be critical of
government because
as i always say to people this is the
biggest challenge governments
the world over have ever faced
in certainly a living memory of the
logistics nature
so i don't i'm not critical of the
government but where
we can propose things that we think are
helpful like for example relying on the
single dose
um you know we'll do it because it's
it's
you might as well everyone can play a
part if they can in trying to get us
through this thing quicker
but i don't i don't talk about the
conversations i have with government
ministers and and i have them on a
private basis it's interesting you say
how
um you don't want to be critical of the
government that they're in this very
unique position
trying to handle the pandemic i mean
some people have made the criticism
recently
of kierstarma that he's calling for
things
when they're inevitable or um
criticizing the government with the
benefit of
hindsight do you think that he needs to
be a bit more constructive to avoid
being seen to be playing politics i
guess in a pandemic
look i think he's actually played it
pretty well you know i mean it's
difficult for him isn't it because
it's a national crisis um
the government is the government and
it's going to be taking the decisions it
takes
you could obviously be critical to a
degree but but i think he's been pretty
constructive all the way through and
he's tried to to
to to suggest things that are helpful
i mean it's a hard position to be in um
as leader of the opposition of these
circumstances and i think he's played it
about right